le drame le drame de vendredi on en a
parlé tous ensemble divine et on en a
beaucoup parlé ce week end
cinquante personnes ont trouvé la mort
dans un terrible attentat survenu dans
deux mosquées en nouvelle zélande une
tuerie diffuser ce qui est absolument
effroyable sur les réseaux sociaux
malgré les tentatives des plateformes de
les interdire c'est un sujet du 20
heures de france 2 dont les 24 heures
qui ont suivi la tuerie de christ church
facebook annonce avoir retiré un million
et demi de copie de la vidéo macabre
filmé par le meurtrier sur facebook
20% des vidéos sont diffusées en direct
elles sont surveillées par trente mille
personnes mais aussi de l'intelligence
artificielle les contenus sensibles
la nudité les actes sexuels la drogue la
torture la violence
nous avons testé la réactivité du réseau
en postant cette image d'une femme nue
dans les deux minutes
l'image était supprimée car contraire
aux règles de facebook pour la violence
c'est moins efficace
le concept violente est pas le même
suivant les et les pays et avec facebook
live en l intelligence humaine va jamais
aussi vite que la diffusion vidéo
instantanée alors facebook a annoncé ce
qui est quand même incroyable avoir
supprimé 1 5 million de vidéos de la
tuerie en 24 heures à quel moment est ce
qu'on a envie de partager ce genre de
vidéos 1,2 million de téléchargements
bloqué et on vient d'apprendre qu'un
jeune homme de 18 ans a été inculpé ce
lundi par un tribunal de christ church
pour avoir relayé la vidéo il risque
jusqu'à 14 ans de prison pour ce délit
voilà pour montrer que ce n'est pas
impuni que ce n'est pas vide de sens de
faire ce genre de chose qu'est ce que
vous en pensez ludivine va commencer par
vous alors évidemment et vous le disiez
à l'instant on en a beaucoup parlé moi
je reste encore vraiment très très
bouleversée voilà par tout ça est
malheureusement alors mes camarades
parleront de censure ou de démago
peut-être de ma part j'en sais rien mais
je pense que tant qu'on sait pas faire
les chiffres nous le prouve
il y a que trente trente mille personnes
pour pouvoir étudier un peu tout ça et
le modérateur pour 30000 modérateur à
gravir le mont pour nettoyer donc tout
ce qui se passe sur facebook on n'y
arrive pas tant qu'on n'y arrive pas on
devrait suspendre le la diffusion en
direct parce que je ne vois pas d'autre
solution pour l'instant pour vous il
faudrait arrêter loire était de le dire
assure sur facebook
le faire on ne sait pas d'accord damian
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
idée de dire de toute façon comme on n'y
arrive pas comme la violence se propage
à vitesse grand v et qu'on peut avoir
accès à des images d'ailleurs qui nous
arrive mètres sans qu'on les demande
il faut arrêter le direct non je ne suis
pas favorable à ce genre de censure
parce que les vidéos en direct c'est une
forme de liberté d'expression on parle
de quoi là on parle d'une minorité de
vidéos qu'une minorité de personnes qui
effectivement ne respectent pas la loi
et commettent des atrocités et se
servent des réseaux sociaux pour les
commettre
après voilà il faut pas non plus
généraliser ce genre de choses pour
autant puisque vous dites ils se servent
des réseaux sociaux pour les comètes est
ce que si on mettait comme comme on peut
faire par exemple dans les direct
différé en télévision on met un direct
différé de deux trois quatre cinq
minutes ce qui permettrait peut-être
d'avoir le temps de réagir et de couper
la vidéo est ce que vous êtes vous
seriez pour je suis et je suis
défavorable a aussi ardemment parce
qu'en fait je pense que ça laisse la
porte ouverte à toutes les dérives
possibles par exemple le gouvernement
pourrait imaginer aussi censuré une
vidéo
parce que ça ne lui plaît pas on
pourrait imaginer toutes sortes de
dérives et vous savez alors évidemment
dans ce cas là c'est normal que les
vidéos soient supprimées il n'y a pas de
débat à ce niveau-là jeu mais je pense
que la violence dans les vidéos reflète
aussi quelque chose dans la société
par exemple les manifestations violentes
en françois-ier par exemple je sais pas
les les dérives dans les abattoirs aussi
on en a beaucoup vu sur les réseaux
sociaux
je pense que c'est important aussi que
nous soyons confrontés à cette violence
pour mieux comprendre la société pour
pour autant lorsque l'on reçoit une
vidéo dans le reportage il était
également fait état de d'un meurtre en
direct qu'on avait vue là c'est cette
tuerie de masse 50 personnes dont on
assiste au massacre et les enfants
c'était effroyable
qu'est ce que vous en pensez dit me bats
comme nous tous un bien sûr j'étais
aussi bouleversée par les images des
gens qui priaient paisiblement le
vendredi qui sont fait massacrer
ça pourrait peut-être arriver un jour
chez nous honnêtement je me pose la
question mais j'espère qu'on sera à
l'abri de tout ça et que l'on fera en
sorte de propager un message de paix
plutôt que de haine néanmoins je suis
alors ça existe une histoire du débit du
de l'enregistrement enfin que j'ai un
petit peu désespéré ça peut être une
solution
je pense que ces entreprises entreprises
dégagent des milliards d'euros des
millions d'euros ils ont les moyens de
contrôler et de mieux gérer pour éviter
ça mais d'un autre côté j'en appelle
aussi à la responsabilité des gens que
cette personne a fait ce massacre cet
attentat c'est une chose qu'elle ne
diffuse
finalement on n'est plus à ça près parce
que on
elle a fait sa bombe à tout on ajoute de
l'horreur à l'horreur et que nous de la
responsabilité personnelle et collective
on est cette vidéo etc on la diffuse moi
des gens m'ont envoyé cette vidéo des
amis de trois amis m'ont enlevé cette
vidéo sans explication je reçois ça une
notification à de sap
je regarde jouer et je tombe sur la
vidéo parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on
est dans une société où la violence est
banalisée du matin au sort nous
expliquer des faits divers un mort c'est
un attentat un sujet idée finalement
basse et des gens comme les autres et
donc nous notre responsabilité c'est ne
pas diffuser c'est de voir cette vidéo
ne pas la propager parce que facebook
twitter instagram pour mettre des
milliards qu'ils veulent mais tant que
nous on aura pas cette responsabilité ce
sens un peu critique et deux raisons on
n'avancera pas et laisse écouter
d'ailleurs une spécialiste dans un
reportage pas celui ci mais un autre qui
expliquait que y compris lorsqu'on
souhaite dénoncer bien s'il faut pas
relayée l'image en question parce que
parfois il nous viendrait à l'idée
peut-être pour pour prouver son
raisonnement est pour pour dénoncer de
remontrer à nouveau aux morts c'est
comme ça que ça ne vient pas grêle et
rendre virale la chose non mais
exactement ça fonctionne pourquoi parce
que l'être humain depuis toujours a eu
cette espèce de curiosité morbide le
goût du sang on va voir à la route
nationale mais j'étais mort mais c'est
encore vous sera j'ai dit oui mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que la force des
réseaux sociaux c'est le live dans le
dans les bons moments comme dans les
moments volés rible vous vous ne voulez
pas qu'on les enchères là dessus et
qu'on stoppe le direct vous me
connaissez moi je suis pour une liberté
quand même plutôt total de s'exprimer
après effectivement à chacun de prendre
ses responsabilités de regarder ou de ne
pas regarder que y ait des modérateurs
sur facebook évidemment il faut qu on
est dix fois plus en sachant que c'est
un réseau social qui a utilisé par des
milliardaires commandes comme vous dites
c'est pas possible comme en suivant par
exemple damien que l'on met à peine deux
minutes pour supprimer 1 50 eur et qu'on
ait mis 15 minutes pour supprimer le
direct de ceux de ce type a besoin parce
que ça fonctionne sur la base de
signalements vous savez il ya 76
terroriste il il a été signalé dry dans
les secondes mais parce que peut-être
qui est aussi un curieux hasard qui fait
que la personne qui se trouvait derrière
l'ordinateur chez facebook a vu cette 6e
signalement à ce moment là mais se
trouve qu'à 75 millions de publications
que ce soit des photos des vidéos des
messages qui sont publiés chaque jour
sur facebook
vous imaginez comment voulez vous que
ces trente mille personnes arrivent à
contrôler qu'elle est
tous devaient donc c'est des êtres germi
effectivement avec l'argent engrangé par
les gaffes et les salons gaza qui se
gavent à milliards ils sont pas capables
d'embaucher d'abord ça résoudrait un
problème de chômage les ja et en plus on
permettrait de résoudre ce genre de
problème non je ne sais juste je ne sais
pas on a on a posé la question à nos
téléspectateurs les images violentes les
réseaux sociaux en font-ils
ac oui ou non on est bien c'est non à
65%
oui pour 35% d'entre vous je pense qu'on
n'a pas fini malheureusement de parler
de ce sujet